- Hey everyone, this is Jeremy Schieffelin
from Khan Academy.
Thanks so much for joining
us in a long running series
of Remote Learning 101.
It's gone on a little
longer than we expected
at the beginning back in March,
but we're happy to serve you
with whatever is most of interest.
We've heard from a lot of
teachers across the country.
They say Yeah, technology is hard
and academics are hard right now.
But motivation and engagement, sparking
that fundamental curiosity
and passion for learning
is really the toughest thing to summon
when everyone's feeling a little down.
And so into that void, has stepped
this amazing Khan Academy
Ambassador, Laura gas,
who is an incredible sixth grade teacher
in Southern California,
and who even before
this crisis started, highly
motivating her students
with a very special part of
Khan Academy that was built
in collaboration with Pixar,
which is called Pixar in a box.
Basically, an online curriculum
that's not about calculus,
or algebra or AP U.S. History,
but about how do you tell
really amazing stories
using both human ingenuity and technology.
And so, I would love for you to learn
from Laura about her experience
and her recommendations.
And I wanna give you a little
bit of an extra bonus today.
In the spirit of Pixar and innovation,
we're gonna try a new
way of asking questions
for these webinars.
So instead of just asking
questions in the question box,
and then waiting to see if
your question will be answered,
we're actually gonna use a new tool,
which you gonna find @khan.co/pixarKhan.
I will chat that into
the chat area right now.
And what you will find when
you get there, is a list
of questions coming in from
teachers across the country
that you can not only add
to, but you can also upvote.
So if you see question that
you're really excited about,
just go ahead and give it a thumbs up,
and those will rise to the top.
And those are the ones that
will turn to Laura first
to make sure they get priority answers.
So that being said,
Laura, we're so excited
to have you here today.
- Thank you
- Thank you again
for sharing your expertise in the midst
of everything else going on.
Take a moment to tell us about
your own educational adventure
and how you got to this moment.
- Well, I'm a teacher here
in Southern California.
I've been teaching about 20 years now.
And I teach in Victor
Elementary School District,
at a school called Galileo Academy.
And I've been there teaching,
I taught third grade
then sixth grade, is what I'm
currently teaching right now.
- That's awesome, and tell
us how things are going,
like how is the remote
learning going for you?
What are you learning along the way?
- Well, I've become much more
technological (laughing).
We've been really doing
a lot of zoom classes
and it's been really great.
I'm able to see the kids
still, and the kids are able
to see me and I'm still
able to give them some,
a lot of different lessons.
Today We even took a virtual tour
of the Great Wall of China.
So, it was pretty neat.
Yeah.
- That's awesome.
Well clearly I can tell that
you're really focused on
that engagement and motivation piece,
as well as the technology piece.
So, why don't you tell
us a little bit more
about Pixar in a Box?
Like, what is it?
And why did you use it in your
classroom in the first place?
- Well, one of the reasons
why I started using it,
I actually started out as an elective.
We were able to choose, each
one of us were able to choose
an elective, something that
we really enjoyed doing,
and not something that
I really enjoyed doing.
I really think that Pixar in a Box is,
the art of storytelling by storytellers.
Which is pretty fantastic.
And so the last couple
of years, I thought,
this is such a fantastic,
just these lessons
are just amazing that I'm
gonna actually use them
in my writing block
rather than just using
them as an elective.
And the kids, absolutely into it.
They really have blossomed as writers
and they really enjoy the process too.
- That's awesome.
And so tell us how you typically
use it with your students.
Like how do you roll it out?
How do you get them excited about it?
- Well, we usually do lessons
per day but, say for example,
the very first lessons.
So we'll go to the art of storytelling.
And in the art of storytelling,
it's just so fantastic, all
of those different lessons
are just all about the storytelling.
So the first thing that I like to do,
is I'd like to show a Pixar short.
What's amazing is Pixar has
so many fantastic shorts
and they are short and
it's so great for the kids
to be able to tell back the
story and they'll be able
to use those to help tell their stories.
So we start with, we are storytellers.
I don't think that the kids realize
what great storytellers they truly are.
They just don't know
how to tell that story.
Or, you know, and they learn
how to do it in a Pixar way.
So, first they learn what
amazing storytellers they are.
In the first lesson, it
talks about the characters
and the unique perspective of characters.
And what we do is, it's so relatable
to the kids because once
we watch the videos,
because that's another
really important piece,
there's always a video on there and Pixar
has allowed us to see a lot
of the different stories
that come from people who
actually work at Pixar
that they are able to
share their stories about
how they became storytellers.
So, then when it asks the
student to do is then allows
the student to self Reflect.
But what's great is most of
these kids have already seen
these Pixar movies.
So, they'll ask you, pick
your three favorite, Okay.
Now let's apply what we've learned.
So, if there are like, for
example, in the first activity
it's about, you know, the emotions
and it's about really starting
to try to express a memory
that they have.
So, they'll take it and they'll
put it in the same concept
as that memory is a story
that I can expand on.
So that's what it asks
the kids to actually draw
on their own experiences to be able to
tell those stories,
which they soon find out
that they are now storytellers.
And then we work into just the structure
of the story or that I've
loved the what if activities.
In one of them, the what if
this happened or that happened.
And what's fantastic is you can take,
say, "The Incredibles",
and then I'll ask the kids,
well, who asked what if?
What is that What if they asked?
And they'll be able to tell me exactly
what if there were superheroes
that couldn't be superheroes anymore?
Well, so there's your story.
And that's how you can start it.
And then after that,
we'll work into character.
The kids will start
creating their characters
which is really fantastic
because once they really get
their character developed,
because we spend
a lot of time on developing
that one character.
So once they get the
character developed using
that internal and
external characteristics,
they have to draw the
character, they have to tell me
who is this?
Do they have a list?
Do they limp?
You know, and so they
have to really define
their characters really well.
And so once they can
define that character,
they can then put the
character into a world.
So then we talk about setting, Okay.
Let's go ahead
and we'll talk about, what kind
of world do you want to live in.
And I love that one piece
where it talks about
the wants versus needs.
Because it's an amazing
way to start the story.
They can, what does your character want?
And what do they need
to do to be able to go
and get what they want?
And then after we get our character,
we wanna know, you know, What's
happening to the character?
Where are their stakes?
You know, those kinds of things.
Then we start looking
into the story structure,
which is where the kids
really start to develop
their story itself.
The one thing that's absolutely
amazing is this story spine.
This story's spine is just something
that gets their juices really flowing.
The once upon a time,
every day until one day
and then because of that, because of that,
because of that, until finally.
And it's a great way to start the story.
Sometimes what we'll do
in class is, I'll put up
the story spine and I
say, "Okay kids, tell me
"once upon a time."
And we'll do it in a
group and then the kids
will tell me once upon, and then I said,
"Okay now, every day what did they do?"
And then somebody will
tell me, this thought
or the other thing.
And then we'll have a class
story that we can repeat
and we Just have a really
good time with that,
because sometimes they
turn out pretty funny.
- You could even do that
over Zoom this days,
have that sort of like,
class wide story building.
- And then after we work
through the story spine,
I love that, the spine then
turns into three different acts.
So then we have act one.
And then we have the
three, there's act one,
beginning, middle and end.
Act one is the once upon a
time, every day, until one day.
So then we work through act one.
And then we go on to act
two, which is the because of,
because of, because of,
and we've worked through that and they get
their middle meat part of the story.
And then finally, we'll
go on to act three,
and that's until finally
and then ever since then.
And then they have a story,
which is really fantastic.
And then after that, what we do
is then we'll start
storyboarding our story.
So we'll work through
that and they can see
what their story is gonna look like.
And then once they have
their story, we were talking
a little bit earlier
about, then they have,
then they really get excited about writing
their story into a script.
So what we then do is we
go to, there's an extension
in Chrome, that is youMeScript.
And the kids can download
this into their Chromebooks
and they can actually write a script.
So, they end up having a
complete story's full script.
And sometimes we talk
about, we're doing this
and we're gonna go from
beginning script to screen and,
so sometimes, if we end
up being able to have
a little bit more time,
we can maybe recorded it
or do a live action or
sometimes they can do claymation
and do a stop motion.
And so they get a complete story.
But the other wonderful thing
about this, we've been talking
about narrative for a while here.
This also, I have used in expository
which has been really great.
We will study something
like the ancient cultures.
And so what we'll do is,
I will give them a prompt
and tell them, "okay,
now you are the character
"in this ancient culture."
So now you can then, they
have to do the research
on their ancient culture, they
have to find out everything
there is to know about that
culture because they have
to be able to write the setting for that.
And then they can have an adventure.
In the meantime, they're also learning
how to write an expository
to be able to show
an ancient culture or even scientist,
they can become scientists too.
- That's awesome.
- Yeah.
- I have to tell you like,
I am super impressed because
not only is everything you
shared the kind of stuff
that I think any student
would love to work
on during normal times, it's
a special kind of material
that a student could work on,
even in these very strange
times, whether it's with
the class or Zoom or on their
own through assignments.
- Yeah.
- That being said, I
know there are a tonne
of questions coming in.
I do wanna remind folks
that if you wanna ask those questions,
it's khan.co/pixarKhan.
And if you don't mind, Laura,
I'd love to start at the top
with some of the top questions coming in.
Okay, so I think this is kind
of the elephant in the room
at this point, which is Laura
is a sixth grade teacher.
But do you have any
recommendations as far as like,
would this work for younger elementary,
would you recommend it all
the way up to high school,
like who is this really for?
- Well, I'm actually going to be,
next year I'm going to
be doing third grade
and I am gonna use it
in my third grade class.
I think this can be used for all ages.
If you're in kindergarten and
first grade, you can do it
as a directed instruction
and they do it a talk through
in kindergarten and first
grade, and even Second grade.
Once you get to third grade, I think this
is really something that they
can absolutely do as well.
When you reach the sixth
grade is just gonna be
a little bit more sophisticated
writing, they're gonna
have a little bit more,
the language is gonna look
a little bit different.
But this can be used, I would
suggest in kindergarten first
and maybe even second, for
it to be a whole class direct
and maybe write a story all together.
But third through six,
it works out wonderfully.
- Great, and we'll also mention,
we've talked mostly about
the storytelling element.
But there are a number of
technical sections focused
on animation and visual
design and all that.
And those are actually
recommended for fifth grade
all the way through high
school with some of the chances
to really apply advanced
offerings, if your students
are hungry for that.
So, definitely serves a wide range.
- Yes, yes.
I'd use the animation
in my sixth grade class,
but some of my kids will come and tell me,
"Oh, we've already done this, you know,
"we did this when I was in fourth grade,
"or we did this when
I was in fifth grade."
So, it depends on, if
the kids really loved it.
Just really go in there
and try and use it.
- Very cool, and then, in
terms of actually finding it,
I'll send out this link again,
but it's basically,
right here in your chat.
And if you ever have any
trouble hunting it down,
just flat out type Pixar
into the search box,
and there you go.
Okay.
So, next question that was coming in is,
that unit that you describe a storytelling
all the way from coming
up with inspiration,
to building a finished script,
how long does it typically take Laura?
- Well, it depends on the group.
And, I think it's really
important to when the kids
are really working hard
and they are so interested
in these things.
Take as much time as the kids wanna take.
I typically will do a lesson a day,
but there's quite a few
times when I'll take, like
the character development, sometimes
they'll take maybe two to three
days, because we really want
to get that character really down.
So, we can put him or her
into, or it, into a whole bunch
of different situations.
So, I would typically do it,
maybe a lesson every two days or so.
The first couple of lessons
are gonna take maybe,
you know, an hour.
But as you work through
it and start getting into
the meat of it, the act, the three acts,
that's gonna take a little bit longer,
maybe two to three weeks
to get through that.
But it's typically, we work on trimesters.
So typically, in a trimester I can have
all the Lessons finished.
- That's great.
So it sounds like if a
teacher started right now,
depending on when their
school schedule goes through,
they could probably finish it up
by the end of the school year.
You'd have a nice thing
to end the summer with.
- Yes, Yes, I think so.
- Great.
Now going back to the
sort of mathematical piece
that we alluded to, the more
technical side of things.
Can you talk about how that
works, what that looks like,
and how you may incorporate
math into some of that?
- Well, that's mostly for the ones that,
when you look at the Pixar in the Box
when you're looking at,
there's with the animation,
they are working through
math with third in artistry.
So, they're just learning how
to plot and how to program,
how to do the animation, how
they're using animations.
So, really in the animation there,
that's where they're using
the mouthpiece there.
We don't do it as much but,
the kids get right in there.
And with the animation, there
are so many tutorials in there
that actually show them
exactly what to do.
And they plot it out for the kids.
And it's so exciting with the one
that you're showing round
now with a bouncing ball,
they get so excited when
they get the bouncing ball.
But most of the kids
will go right in there,
and plot it themselves.
- Very cool.
And then just sort of expand upon
what we were talking about before.
For each of these more technical sections,
there's both an introduction,
and then a more advanced
mathematical section.
So if you have fifth
graders, you can start with
the intro and stop there.
If you have middle or high schoolers,
you can even go all the way to the end.
- Exactly.
- Great.
What do you think about this
as a whole course versus supplement?
Think it goes back to
that elective versus integrated approach?
- Well, I have to say that when I gave it
as an elective, I only had an
hour, maybe a couple of days
a week, and the kids
wanted more, more and more.
And because they've really enjoyed it,
they also enjoy watching
the Pixar movies in short.
So everybody wanted to be in
that particular elective.
But, I think that this is
such an incredible program,
Pixar in the Box, that it it
helps the students so much
with their writing and
their writing block.
I think it's just, I use
it in my writing block,
and I will continue to
use it in my writing book
for my whole class, from now on because,
I just think the quality of their writing
that's coming out is fantastic.
And then when they writing in the scripts,
they also start learning about dialogue,
and they also start learning about,
they learn about how to place the action
and those sorts of things
and, I just like it.
I would recommend doing
it as a writing block.
- Wonderful.
I know folks are asking
about Google Classroom,
which is something that
you mentioned to me before
we got started here.
What do you recommend there
as far as the integration?
- Well, I really have to
say, Khan Academy has done
an amazing, and Pixar together,
have done an amazing job
with creating the Pixar
in a Box when the lesson.
So the lessons are just
right there for you.
But then what I would
do is, I would go ahead
and create a Google Classroom.
And then you can share
that with your students
and that gives your
students an opportunity
to start adding all of the
lessons there, so you can see
all the different things they're doing.
I've had quite a few
students, what they'll do is
they'll take pictures of their character
with them, side by side and
they'll send that to me.
You can have each, you can
separate your Google Classroom
into different activities.
Start with the storytelling
activity 1, 2, 3, 4
and then work it that way.
And then you're able to
see what the kids are able
to create when you're there.
And then we also do, you know,
our distance learning Zoom
meetings, and kids are able
to share all of their
information that way too.
But I think Google
Classroom is probably one
of the best ways to get
some assignments and be able
to give your kids some feedback
on how well they're doing.
- That's great.
And so we do something as simple
as take that URL right out
of the assignment or the
exercise, and then paste it
into an assignment in Google Classroom.
- That's it.
- Okay, cool.
That's awesome.
As far as a teacher guide,
obviously it's gonna feel
a little overwhelming
at first cause it's such
a big piece of content.
Any sort of resources you
found that are useful for like,
digging in and making those first steps.
- Well, again, when you're going
to the Pixar in a Box,
what I would suggest doing
is just looking at that educators guide
and it really will explain a lot of the,
what's behind Pixar on a box?
And how the lessons were created.
And I would just go through
each one of the lessons.
And teachers are just
amazing kinds of people,
they always take things and they do it
and make it their own.
Some of the things that
I have done, I have added
a little bit to their learning.
So really look at it and
try to make it your own.
You might see something and
go, "Oh, this is fantastic.
"That's why I added
bragging scripts to it."
I would suggest going
through each, look at
that educators guide and
then I would actually look
through each one of the lessons.
And they're pretty straightforward
because they've done a great
job at explaining exactly
what they want the student to learn.
- That's awesome.
Okay we shared that link there.
I know someone else is
asking for a link to
that script writing extension,
we'll put that in as well.
Let's see what else here.
Can we see a finished product?
You don't have to violate any
of your student's confidentiality or PII,
but can you give folks a sense of like,
what your sixth graders
are coming up with?
- Well, I've been getting a
lot of stories about unicorns.
(laughing)
A lot of pictures of unicorns
and things like that.
I wish I could, I had
some of those things,
but we left before we got to get
a lot of the finished products.
But, a lot of the students,
some of the students
will come up with amazing
narrative scripts about things
that are happening in their own lives,
and, I just I wish I had some to show you
but, you're gonna be
amazed at what you find
and what you guys are gonna get.
Some of the pictures that they draw for me
and then with the characteristics,
you have to draw on
the outside, the external and
then the inside, the internal
and some of the pictures
these guys are sending me,
you can tell they really enjoy it.
- That's awesome and
especially right now I think.
You know, like talking about
the really tough emotions of this moment.
And for students to
have an outlet to share
how they're feeling, even
if it's through a fictional scripts,
like it's so powerful to be
able to get that out there.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
As far as the scripting piece,
I don't know if you're able
to speak to this Laura, but have you heard
of anyone doing something
similar on an iPad,
if they don't have access to Chromebooks?
Maybe a scripting app
or something like that.
- You should be able to,
if you go into Chrome
and you're opened up, you
should be able to access
the YouMeScript on any
device that you have.
I haven't had any one tell me
that they haven't been able
to access it because it's an
actual, app that comes from
the Chrome Web Store.
- Yeah.
- So if you
have Chrome you should be
able to find and have it.
- So it looks like the extension
is a nice thing if you do
have Chromebooks, but even if
you just have a web browser,
like Safari on an iPad, you
can still go to youmescript.com
and get started it looks like.
- you should be able to do that.
Yeah.
- Great.
Then sort of the question around,
isolation versus whole unit,
obviously, there's a huge
cornucopia of lessons here.
Do you think it's okay just
to sort of pick and choose,
like hey, if they wanna do
a little bit of geometry
or a little bit of stat,
or is it really better
to go through that full
unit of storytelling?
- Well, it's better to
go from beginning to end,
especially with storytelling.
Now with the animation,
some of them build upon the other ones.
So it's really better
to go in the sequence
of how the lessons are provided for you.
- Makes sense, Yeah, I think
storytelling is such a like,
additive cumulative process,
that you don't wanna just dip
in and out for that one.
What about this question,
especially for younger students.
So maybe like, sixth graders and below,
obviously anytime you have
students who are under 13,
there are very specific policies in place
when it comes to technology.
Do your students actually
have Khan Academy logins,
or is that actually irrelevant?
Every single one of my kids
has Khan Academy login.
That's one thing that we have emphasized.
It's been incredible to be able
to be a Khan Academy ambassador
because I've been able to,
specifically at my site, be able to show
all the teachers how
to get on Khan Academy,
how to get their classroom
set up, all of that.
And so they are able to, every single one
of our teachers are
able to use Khan Academy
and they all have their own
accounts on Khan Academy.
- Great, I'll just mention
like, I think that's probably
the best scenario in the sense
that that way, you can track
their progress using Khan Academy reports
and things like that.
However, I know these are
very different circumstances
than we're used to.
And so if you're just like,
I wanna roll this out,
but I don't have time for
another platform, another set
of passwords, like we were
just saying a second ago,
you can always come
over to Google Classroom
or whatever LMS is, and just
flat out paste the URL in.
Anyone can access it,
even without a login.
- Right.
- and then just say,
"Hey, send me your finished product.
"Send me your brainstorm,
send me your script,
"send me whatever."
And then, your students
get all the benefit
of all this goodness, without having
to create another password,
another registration process.
So, just throwing it out there.
Let's see here.
Here's a really interesting question
around special education students.
So actually, we did a session
dedicated to this audience
a couple weeks ago, which was one
of our most registered sessions ever.
And there's a real concern right now
that I think, every student feels like
they're being left behind in some ways,
but special education students
have unique challenges
that we have to solve
as educators right now.
Do you think that this program could work
for that audience and drive
that same level of engagement?
- Yeah absolutely.
I work pretty closely
with our special ed team.
And I'll go back to when I
was doing it as an elective.
I had some of the kids that were from sped
that came into my classroom
and they were going through
all the lessons together with us.
But we work closely
together and I absolutely,
some of those sped kids
have great imaginations,
and i think that they can
do it without any problems.
- Cool.
Yeah, it does feel like this
is really happening something,
pretty universal in this moment,
which is our desire to tell our stories.
And doesn't matter where
you're coming from or whatever,
like this is a chance to
really have that outlet.
- Great.
- Cool.
Well, I know we're at
the bottom of the hour,
and I wanna respect your time law,
cause I know you have your
own students to serve.
Any final words of wisdom that you
wanna leave your fellow
educators with, as they go off
on their own journeys.
- Like I say, Pixar in a Box,
it's just the art of storytelling.
And we are gonna create a generations,
if we continue to use this.
We're gonna create a
generation of storytellers,
which I think is gonna be fantastic.
And, I would just keep
plugging away and, like I say,
it's very straightforward,
it's pretty easy to use,
and, you just can't imagine
the wonderful stories
that you're gonna get from your kids.
- Cool.
I think that's what we all need
a little bit more of right now.
Right, thank you for
sharing your story, Laura.
And then I wish everyone else
incredible adventures yet
to come and stories yet to be written.
And please, please, please
wish you all incredible success
on that tough road ahead.
Thank you so much, Laura.
Thanks to everyone.
Hi y'all.